you
remember the Jetsons okay
it's probably a little before our time
at least for many people watching this
video even microsoft word gave me the
red squiggly line under the title but
not too long ago shows like The Jetsons
depicted a future full of exciting new
technology most memorably the flying car
a few decades ago kids grew up hoping to
one day fly to work in their very own
sky car but that vision has clearly not
become a reality these days that dream
is all but forgotten what happened to
the flying car to understand the
public's fascination with flying cars we
have to travel back to the early days of
automobiles it might surprise you that
one of the earliest proponents of the
idea wasn't some eccentric inventor but
one of the great visionaries of
automotive history Henry Ford the man
behind the company responsible for such
legends as the Model T the gt40 and the
mighty Pinto as early as 1926 Ford
sparked public interest in affordable
aircraft for the everyman by producing a
tiny single-seat plane called the
flivver under the specifications that it
fit inside his office the flivver
prototype was a flop heralded as a
horrible craft and accounted for one
fatality an employee and personal friend
of Henry Ford Harry Brooks regardless of
the project's failure the idea of
cost-effective privately owned air
transportation was a hit the following
decade saw several craft similar to the
Ford sliver and in 1940 Ford himself
stated mark my word
a combination airplane and motorcar is
coming you may smile but it will come
low and behold in 1946 a man named Ted
Hall an employee with consolidated volte
aircraft ignited public interest with
his very own flying car prototype the
design was finally becoming a proper car
airplane hybrid featuring a detachable
wing and separate engines for the car
and playing portions Paul intended for
civilians to own the car but rent the
wing from their local airport any time
they wanted to fly somewhere Paul's
initial prototype dubbed the convair
model 116 was a two-seater powered by a
rear-mounted 26 horsepower engine for
the car and an additional 90 horsepower
engine to drive the plane portions
propeller not exactly a powerhouse of a
vehicle but it got the job done the
model 116 successfully completed 66 test
flights and was followed by a more
refined model 118 which featured a four
seat plastic bodied car driven by a 25
horsepower engine and a much more
powerful 190 horsepower flight engine
everything was going according to plan
and for the convair car until in
November of 1947 human error threw a
wrench in things test pilot Reuben
Snodgrass who was by all accounts a
fantastic pilot was forced to crash-land
the 118 in a field one hour into his
flight Snodgrass escaped with minor
injuries but the wing was damaged and
the car was destroyed the cause of the
crash was pretty embarrassing for an
experienced pilot like Snodgrass since
the model 118 was technically two
separate pieces it also had two separate
fuel tanks before takeoff Snodgrass had
checked the car's fuel level but had
neglected to check the airplanes tank
the flight engine ran out of fuel and
caused the crash landing the company had
a backup prototype to continue test
flights but the damage was done public
interest in the project waned and the
model 118 never made it into production
the convair car showed that it was
possible to create a hybrid plane
automobile and despite the project's
failure the idea of flying cars was
still at the top of the list for
projected future travel fast-forward to
the early 1970s and we get another group
keen to be the first to mass-produce
this private air travel contraption this
company based out of California was
known as advanced vehicle engineers or a
ve and their plan was very nearly
identical to halls they plan to
mass-produce the airplane part of the
vehicle to be rented out from airports
around the country the more interesting
part of the story is that the car
portion of their project was originally
intended to be a Pontiac Firebird
perhaps in hopes of luring more people
in with the temptation of a flying
muscle car however that idea was
scrapped and the hybrid which was dubbed
the Mizar ended up going with the
infamous Ford Pinto like to model 1:18
the Mizar very nearly made it into
production and human error once again
dashed the hopes of all those behind the
project at least those who survived the
flying Pinto was plagued by design and
construction flaws as test pilot Charles
Janis discovered firsthand during a
short flight in August of 1973
not long after takeoff the right wing
strut based mounting attachment failed
meaning the car was attached to the
plane at only one side Janis knew that
if he tried to turn the whole thing was
liable to come apart so instead he flew
straight and managed to land at a nearby
bean field and proceeded to drive the
damaged Mizar back to the airport not
one month later and apparently
undeterred by this critical design flaw
Mizar creator Henri Smolinski and
vice-president of a ve Harold Blake
conducted a test flight themselves
unsurprisingly the right wing straw
again detach from the Pinto when
Smolinski attempted to turn it around
the right-wing folded and sent the Mizar
straight into the ground resulting in an
explosion that killed both executives
and with them the Mizar project
unbeknownst to the two unfortunate
victims they also supposedly ruined what
could have been a very cool addition to
the 1974 Bond movies the man with the
Golden Gun as before the crash the
film's bad guy was intended to escape in
a Mizar but after the accident it ended
up being replaced with a model with the
two biggest flying car projects ending
in spectacular fashion you'd think that
the dream would have faded long ago but
there are still a few groups trying to
get there prototypes off the ground as
it were one such company a small
American corporation known as Terrafugia
is currently working on its own roadable
airplane known as the transition which
has been in development since 2006 its
primary function is as a light-sport
aircraft but it has the ability to fold
its wings for use on public roads and it
can travel at up to 70 miles per hour in
normal traffic conditions as successful
or rather disaster-free as the
transition is it hasn't exactly caused
much excitement why is that if you look
at today's society it's much different
than when flying cars for a novel
concept back in Henry Ford's day
automobiles were much more of a luxury
than they are today when it's not
uncommon to see teenagers owning cars
the greater number of cars on the roads
and the increased number of distractions
like cell phones have shown us just how
untrustworthy most people are behind the
wheel putting those same people at the
controls of a flying vehicle is
unthinkable
however driving as we know it is quickly
becoming a thing of the past our cars
seemed to be more computer than machine
these days and that's changed the way
we're approaching the transportation of
the near future we've now turned to such
advancement as self-driving cars which
are creeping closer and closer to
eliminating the need for human input
entirely this notion of vehicular
autonomy is perhaps the saving grace of
the flying car if these vehicles had no
option for human control and were more
akin to large transport drones than
planes we could potentially see a
resurgence of the idea of personal air
transport removing human error the main
cost for failure and past endeavours
could rekindle public interest in Jetson
style flying vehicles the automotive
landscape is changing who knows what
we'll see in the future if you'd like to
learn more about the history of flying
cars and current projects check out the
links in the description
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
subscribe to keep up to date with the
latest content you can watch my previous
video by clicking here or watch them all
by clicking here thanks for watching and
I'll see you in the next video